[Musica]
a tono con belle ho 39 anni ed al 36
vivono e molto del silenzio la bambina
curiosa e lo 40 all'improvviso all'età
di tre anni sono stata catapultata se
punto impianto in fondo dove non c'era
più alcuna forma per il suo le parole in
un board la musica ovviamente ero ancora
troppo piccola per capire quello che mi
stava succedendo
ecco cv praticamente non sapevo cosa
fare e per me era tutto un gioco infatti
dovevo imparare a leggere le parole alle
labbra e alle persone e doveva dare un
significato a tutti i suoni sembrano
diventati a tratti non vi fate credere
portati gli effetti vivere nel mondo del
silenzio quali sono le sensazioni le
quali sono le mete sfumature che si
possono essere nel mondo del cilento e
della disabilità uditiva quindi ora
parole le piccole simulazioni perché
te.am e dopo quell'esperienza che ti può
avvicinare un pochettino al mondo per
silenzio e capire che cosa significa ok
tranquilli buona la reed crawford che
non funzionava realtà questo quello che
noi viviamo ogni giorno
allora proverò a parlarmi ma è tra
lingua
[Musica]
in questo momento mi sto parlando
un'altra lingua la lingua dei segni
italiana è una lingua come tutte le
altre strutture regola grammaticale come
qualsiasi altra lingua portiamo in
tavola lingua 36 francese eccedenza
inglese molto probabilmente molti di voi
non la conoscono perché voi si attacchi
fatti a vivere nel mondo al sonoro
errata questa lingua pasta dal canale
visivo sessuale bianca questa lingua
parte delle giorni verso te la vita
quindi tarditi va cuore vi voglio fare
un'altra piccola prova a mette mano i
tappi arato quelli battete era le
foglietta alla fine di questo video ma
se vi faccio a vedere
ok
avete tutti i papi ha fatto a mano così
libero x factor mi piace pronti
quindi altri ma davvero molto semplice
che era va bene tu sei nero
[Musica]
togliete fatti allora ma avete sentito
ok alla capita qualcosa sicuramente
qualcuno ha capito che di più e di meno
che niente anche perché sono tutte il
fumatore che fanno parte del mondo della
città qualità uditiva i tempi di più si
sente di vero e poi l'ha quindi questo è
il bello della diversità che la
ricchezza presente nel pronto te la
disabilità uditiva
ma un'altra volta che ti voglio far
notare è che molto probabilmente voglia
alphabet avuto difficoltà sia a vedere
la pubblicazione iata la comunicazione
dal punto di vista ambientale a un po
pericolosa infatti in qualsiasi luogo
faccenda di più poveri fazione e quindi
praticamente per noi che non sentiamo
sempre qualsiasi comunicazione sonora o
qualsiasi comunicati o devo palo allarme
non sempre riusciamo a partecipare
attivamente infatti crescendo ho capito
che qualsiasi paesaggio sonoro diventava
inaccessibile elio diventava sempre più
consapevole per i miei limiti e fatto il
pit o moret appunto piano chiaro che noi
per torneo torti viviamo in fondo tutte
la comunicazione sonora è il canale
primario e quindi non richiamo a
partecipare attivamente a tutto ciò capo
mentazione sonora bhopal
vi faccio un esempio cremati troviamo di
fronta no colorni matt emergenza la
premo il pulsante per pa parla oppure
magari colpa di chiamata vocale
apparentando di un pronto soccorso
dovrebbe porto ritrovare ore ora ad
accettare senza capire il perché
oppure semplicemente per fare il finto
di sopravvivenza quanto più stato una
stazione ferroviaria e mi ritrovo a
guardare il monitor che non funzione
questi mi metto a spezzare le persone
per te che quella persone si muovono da
un fatto ordinario
oppure ancora hanno puntato in pre
matico comunque stata
da qualsiasi luogo pubblico o partiamo
in luogo di lavoro dove l'allarme sonoro
no non sappiamo che mangiamo qui poi bel
giorno sono in parte marce un toro fa
normata propagate nel progetto pazza qui
devo fare qualcosa per farsi per ogni
luogo tia microchip copiate l'argento ne
è l'emblema dell'accessibilità sala
fluttuanti era tra i telai m affittato
robusti passiamo ma non era accessibile
nel vostro pato infatti per appunto la
mia storia chiaro all'interno di questo
centro al buio punta al bravo il
pulsante e questo voto cominciò a
parlare io per il mio tolte pinto di top
rope idee sono portata in cui faccio
ancora fanno bloccata in quei pazienti
avevano fissato un posto accezioni ecco
mi parlava da solo io anche
eravamo come due rette parallele forte
volte ti fanno poi incontrate perché la
cintura già per ma per me quello è stato
il pupo fatale e da quel giorno
l'accenture è diventato un modello di
riferimento infatti portate ci poteva
trovare in qualsiasi ambiente che sia
pubblico che sia una città il gas serra
è così entrato giusto di fare
architettura e ti pare nella vita quello
che volevo farti architetto ma dal mio
punto di vista
poi è arrivato il giorno dell'esame di
stato e mi hanno chiesto ma ti assicuro
che vuoi fare l'architetto ma io ho
portati per presa come per dire qual è
il problema
ecco da una vita a mente difficile che
ti può farne la vita quotidiana
all'università uova l'aniene relazioni
sociali gli altri problemi ci potevano
essere tirata po troppo entrata nel
mondo del lavoro
ho capito che la musica è cambiata è la
realtà era diventata molto più dura
perchè ogni giorno dovremmo fronteggiare
situazioni poi è morto dobbiamo cercare
di superare le difficoltà ma non sempre
ci riuscivo e quindi ho deciso di
definire la mia nuova vita attraverso la
teoria
ecco allora la teoria della iii
discriminazioni tifato è però appunto da
episodio emblematico per farti capire la
mafia vediamo allora immagina come che
per la prima volta sono direttore del
cantiere e vedeva presentata la squadra
di muratori primati quella volta più top
buongiorno da market è arrivato
l'architetto di turno con tutto quello
che ne consegue che fa lavoro di
architetto e queste sicuramente molti di
voi conoscono questo problema già
puntati livello medio alto
sono comunque a noi ci dobbiamo far
comandare da una donna arriva allora
tutto quello che ne consegue per chi
come me è donna e le proprio fessionisti
non molto tipicamente macchio patate
quello che fa tritare tutte le antenne
che lasciati i veneti e peccati una
torta signoraggio totale dall altra
parte questa volta è completo
se mi presento nel mondo del lavoro la
prima volta che entrò subito cosa pace
la sfida mi ha aperto la porta perché
dovevo vedere le persone che ritrova
sennò mi veniva vantiamo 5 la vibrazione
oppure quanto dovevo interagire con i
pollai di è passato che votare dobbiamo
perdere lavoro per fare la lapi lettura
quanto mia racconti antichi il cantiere
lasciamo stare fra le mappature spazia
tool di clienti telefonavamo e quindi
non mi sentivo tranquilla all'interno di
quell'ambiente dovevo fare qualcosa
mancava 4.000 più ma se cambiamo punto
al di vetta e cominciamo a fare
mare di comunicazione considan provato a
macinare mai dobbiamo punto talmente
social siamo merci foto dove la
comunicazione in realtà non è solo
sonora
la mappa tattile un tuono un colore una
evoluzione dal un po parlata la lingua
accennata tuttora comunicazione provate
a immaginare quanto sarebbe bello e
fondò porta potrebbe essere lì con fondo
dovevo come le chiama con qualsiasi
modalità qualsiasi limbach e
separatamente 30 watt e questa secondo
me è la chiave che apre tutte le porte
che per me è stata una persona con
disabilità che un turiano cognitiva di
poter essere definita per quello che
sono le armi per azione è così ho
cominciato a protestare assalto proprio
dalla comunicazione che mancava in
qualsiasi progetto di accessibilità è
così che è nato accessi walmart un 2
questo è nato proprio con l'obiettivo di
avere una comunicazione inclusiva nei
quartieri ambiente altresì palmari è
noto proprio dalla stessa condurrà mia e
di qualsiasi persona con rohtak è nato
dalla fisica
vi faccio vedere una pianta come tipo
poi pensate con la pioggia e
tranquillità io faccio sempre le persone
fuori dalla porta poi siano l'acqua
aperta a metà apporto quando arriva la
famiglia oppure costerebbe iacono io
continua tormeno indisturbata il figlio
e palmer del forno o della fuga del tar
non mi passa neanche per l'anticamera
il cervello per risolta ma almeno dal
punto di vista ambientale e cercare di
comunicare almeno delle altre principali
modalità vibrazione è un debito o
progettato questo sistema che consenta
appunto la traduzione la codificazione
di tutti gli allarmi sonori all'interno
di un ambiente di più modalità di
comunicazione tra questi praticamente in
qualsiasi ambiente
abbiamo una segnalazione da piazza per
tutti gli allarmi sia visivamente non
può i dispositivi mobili oa di frazione
guardate questo il primo esempio
all'appartamento
ovviamente quando vedete a questo ha
fatto ne devi sempre avanti ipoteca a
l'aquila lo acquista anche una funzione
di comunicazione porta che di
illuminazione per fatti puntate la
tipologia di colore vi segnala proprio
l'allarme che è passato e questa la
chiamo fratè parla il tempo a casa di
riposo
ovviamente il città sarà
personalizzabile per te per ogni
tipologia cambiate ti rispondeva proprio
alle richieste degli allarmi specifici
ovviamente poi quanto abbiamo fatto
alberto mi sono resa conto per chiariti
da fare è tornato a quota importante
praticamente oltre al telefono per la
comunicazione fra la chat e l'unep
abbiamo aggiunto la chat e quindi
abbiamo dato la possibilità alla persona
quantità di talenti ti va di lavorare
alla reception cosa che prima non poteva
fare quindi abbiamo qui se questa è
anche per conclusione ovviamente crati
alla ricerca del libro di questo
protesto favorita punto cali reti ora
partito solo per le persone per le
persone quantità che tanti ti va di peso
con il tempo e con l'evoluzione è
diventato sempre più numerazione
infatti sono state bene per una persona
anziano con paolo potito per chi ha
portato a tutto volume per una persona
sorto ceca per chi lavora un ambiente
rumoroso perché è semplicemente di
sfratto o per chi magari stamattina non
italiane anche quelle pallonate ma con
la di trazione cina e non ho finito non
mi permetto certo qui ovviamente
continuo a lavorare ea esplorare finito
volto della comunicazione implosiva non
sempre più luoghi protetti e un
obiettivo sempre fermo di farci che si
abbia la partecipazione di ogni
cittadino per partite ogni cittadino si
possa muovere in autonomia per parte
però io cittadino possa sentirsi
finalmente lei però entrati o il
silenzio mio fratello e compagno di vita
per segnalata la possibilità di
diventare una libera professionista è di
poter risolvere situazioni d'attore agli
altri non riescono quindi se da una
parte il silenzio poteva essere il mio
grande limite invece alla fine tiene
prato opportunità per cui oggi sono qui
a dirvi se dovete imparare a vedere al
di là di otto i limiti dovete imparare a
vedere le ritorte dovete imparare a
vedere le opportunità e per porto non è
facile è difficile ma si può
ap a credere nei propri sogni credere
che le proprie passioni e andare avanti
sempre avanti un tema cuore grazie
dell'attenzione mille
[Applauso]
[Musica]